we're going to leave you with some good
vibes of the day
celebs are showing love and support on
social media for julie rohr an edmonton
woman with terminal cancer stars like
ryan reynolds glennon doyle dan and
eugene levy and many more are lifting
her spirits with their heart-warming
video messages now taking to social
media re-sharing ryan's video julie
writes this oh my goodness gracious my
heart feels absolutely ready to explode
i am so overwhelmed and honored thank
you for your kindness and sending this
message last night was one of the
hardest in my life and today is just
coming up roses
well hey there julie it's ryan reynolds
i just want to send you this little
video and let you know that i'm thinking
about you um i heard a little bit about
your story and uh
um one of the things that struck me
about your story is that you uh you you
are beloved uh by so many people um
enough people that that uh that message
got all the way to me out here in boston
um anyway i want to send lots of love i
know you've been going through it um
stay strong
hope i get to meet in person one of
these days bye julie dan levy here
on behalf of the cast and crew of shits
creek
we
are so glad that you loved our show
we're so glad that it has brought you
joy
and we are all each and every one of us
sending you so much love right now